wenn da jetzt noch irgendwas drüber
kommt dann dann raste ich aus
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein Plätzchenrezept und
ihr findet schon viele viele
Plätzchenrezepte auf meinem Kanal in
meiner App und auf meinem Blog das heißt
falls ihr was Schönes für Weihnachten
sucht dann schaut da gerne mal vorbei
heute gibt's mal Kronen ich liebe ja
Kokosmakronen nussmakronen was ich aber
auch sehr liebe sind schokoladenmakronen
und die werde ich jetzt heute zubereiten
ich zeige euch mal die Zutaten was ich
immer ganz gut finde das ist halt so ein
Rezept was mit Eiweiß zubereitet wird
und das Eigelb könnt ihr dann
aufbewahren und damit z.B einen
Mürbeteig zubereiten für Plätzchen das
heißt beim Plätzchen backen ist es
selten dass man ein ganzes Eifer
verwendet man hat immer Eiweiß oder
Eigelb und wenn ihr dann die Rezepte so
aussucht dass ihr das Eiweiß dafür und
das Ei gibt dafür benutzt dann habt ihr
immer alle Zutaten schön verbraucht und
habt eben auch nichts übrig ich habe
jetzt hier drei Eiweiß eine Prise Salz
150g Zucker 100 g Zartbitter Kuvertüre
40g Mandeln die sind bereits gemalen
Tonka Paste und hier habe ich noch
backen die gibt's in zwei verschiedenen
größ die gibt es jetzt auch in
Bio-Qualität und ihr könnt jetzt
überlegen ob ihr große Makronen macht
oder kleine die großen nehme ich
tatsächlich gerne für Lebkuchen
Elisenlebkuchen und die kleinen nehme
ich jetzt ganz gerne für die Makronen
genau so viel dazu das Rezept ist auch
echt schnell ihr könnt das super schnell
zubereiten ganz einfach und macht am
besten gleich die doppelte Menge dann
habt ihr einen Arbeitsschritt und
wirklich ganz viele Plätzchen
gleichzeitig das Eiweiß kommt jetzt hier
in eine fettfreie saubere Schüssel das
ist auch wichtig dass auch kein Eigelb
Rückstand mit dabei ist sonst wird das
Eiweiß nicht steif dann etwas Salz dazu
das zerstört schneller die Eiweiß
Struktur und es geht eben auch schneller
und jetzt ein bisschen rühren
und sobald schaumig ist einfach den
Zucker langsam dazugeben dann auf
höchste Stufe stellen und richtig schön
glänzend verrühren bis sich der Zucker
gelöst hat also ungefähr 10 Minuten
und in der Zwischenzeit kann ich dann
schon mal die Zartbitterkuvertüre fein
reiben
[Musik]
bei der Schokolade solltet ihr darauf
achten dass ihr eine gute qualitative
Schokolade nehmt denn nur so gut wie die
Schokolade ist kann am Ende auch dann
Plätzchen schmecken es gibt jetzt hier
rein und reibe sie fein wenn ihr
Schokolade am Block habt könnt ihr auch
eine Reibe nehmen aber das schmilzt
immer ganz gerne in der Hand also finde
ich so eine Reibe immer viel viel besser
und hier das Eiweiß so lange rühren bis
keine Zuckerkristalle mehr zu sehen oder
zu fühlen sind also wenn ihr so in den
Fingerspitzen so ein bisschen Eiweiß
gleich nehmen einfach keinen
zuckerkristall mehr spürbar sein
[Musik]
so sieht die Masse perfect aus richtig
schön glänzend und das Eiweiß ist steif
geschlagen dann brauche ich jetzt keine
Küchenmaschine mehr ihr solltet jetzt
auch wenn ihr jetzt Schokolade und
Mandeln dazu gibt oder auch bei
Kokosmakronen haselnussmakronen egal bei
welchem Gebäck auch immer alles was
fettig ist und jetzt mit reinkommt soll
nur untergehoben werden ansonsten fällt
es Eiweiß nämlich zusammen und das
wollen wir nicht ich liebe dich
warte mal wie so eine Wolke
süße Wolke
oh das sind nämlich immer dran wie
Samira immer dachte man kann auch Wolken
laufen wenn man vom Flugzeug aussteigen
wenn ihr ein edelstahlelement habt dann
darf es auch in die Spülmaschine und
dann gebt ihr jetzt hier die Schokolade
rein die Mandeln und etwas Tonka und
könnte das Ganze schön unterheben
und am einfachsten ist es jetzt ihr
nehmt euch einen Spritzbeutel mit zum
Beispiel einer fein gezackten Sterntülle
oder einer Lochtülle ihr könnt natürlich
auch mit einem Eisportionierer arbeiten
aber ich finde gerade so eine
Makronenmasse die lässt sich mit dem
Spritzbeutel einfacher auftragen und ihr
seid halt auch echt viel schneller
fertig
[Musik]
ein ausrichtet schon so gut ich könnte
das einfach jetzt so löschen ich sag's
euch
Tonka
Schokolade Mandeln das ist die beste
Mischung
mit so einer Teigkarte könnte das dann
immer so ein bisschen nach vorne
schieben
okay ich merke schon mein Lieblingspulli
aber nicht zum Backen die Arme rutschen
immer runter
und hier seht ihr die fein gezackte
Sterntülle
eine schöne große Öffnung des letzten 17
mmhülle und den Ofen habe ich jetzt auch
schon vorgeheizt kann jetzt hier meine
Opladen nehmen und am besten macht ihr
so hier oben schön zu halten
dann die Oblate in die Hand nehmen und
einfach so ein kleines Häufchen da drauf
spritzen und mit etwas Abstand aufs
Backblech denn Makronen gehen im Ofen
immer noch so ein bisschen auf
[Musik]
lighting alive
44 Makronen und ein kleines Häufchen die
kommen jetzt in den vorgeheizten
Backofen bei 130 Grad Heißluft so kann
ich beide Bleche gleichzeitig backen und
da backen Sie ungefähr 25 Minuten ich
mache jetzt hier kurz sauber
und ich zeige euch glaube ich noch ein
zweites Rezept heute
zur Feier des Tages gibt
für das zweite Rezept verwende ich 100 g
Mandeln 130 g in steinte Datteln 60 g
Cranberries 90 g Orangensaft 100 g zarte
Haferflocken einen Esslöffel Lebkuchen
oder Spekulatius Gewürz Backofen jetzt
nehme ich die 70 mm Backofen und zum
Dekorieren noch ein paar essbare
goldsterne das zweite Rezept sind nicht
gebackene Müsli Snacks und die sind
schön weihnachtlich weil ich nämlich
Spekulatius Gewürz mit dazu gebe und es
ist einfach was Schönes was ihr mit zur
Schule nehmen könnt mit ins Büro mit zur
Arbeit einfach im Kühlschrank
aufbewahren könnt und dann habt ihr eben
was richtig leckeres was soll ich satt
macht und was auch noch gesund ist denn
ich mag ganz gerne Müsli ich mag kein
Porridge und das ist sozusagen ein Müsli
to go kann man so schön abbeißen
deswegen könnt ihr hier wie gesagt diese
Trockenfrüchte verwenden ich habe jetzt
Datteln und Cranberries ihr könnt auch
zeigen Aprikosen Pflaumen was auch immer
ihr da habt einfach verwenden und auch
untereinander mischen hauptsache ihr
habt später eine gute
klebrige Konsistenz ich habe jetzt hier
richtig gute Datteln die sind schon
schön klebrig manche Datteln sind aber
auch schon relativ trocken die könnt ihr
aber auch zum Beispiel mit heißem Wasser
aufgießen und dann sind sie auch klebrig
ich habe jetzt hier die Mandeln die
werden zerkleinert
da kommen dann die Datteln und
Cranberries mit rein auch schön
zerkleinern
Orangensaft dazu
ist auch schön Vitamin C dabei
Haferflocken
und
Spekulatius gewesen
und schön durchrühren ihr könnt es auch
verkneten könnt auch für mich
okay am besten mixt ihr diese Masse hier
nochmal gut durch damit sie so wie hier
schön klebrig ist und gerade wenn ihr
zum Beispiel keine zarten Haferflocken
habt ist sowieso besser man Mix alles
noch mal durch damit eben hier alles
klebrig und schön ist dann nehmt ihr
euch die Backofen
könnt ihr euch so vor euch hinlegen dann
eine mittlere Eisportionierer Form voll
in die Mitte
deckt es mit einer zweiten Oblate ab und
dann nimmt ihr am besten einfach ein
Glas
könnt so ein bisschen flach drücken dann
gehen die Opladen auch nicht kaputt denn
wenn ihr mit den Fingern drückt kann
sein dass jetzt zerbrecht und dann habt
ihr ein schönes kleines Müsli Sandwich
[Musik]
was schon dann sind die Snacks schon
fertig und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
jetzt noch hergehen und mit essbaren
stiften mit Lebensmittelfarben dann noch
was drauf schreiben auf die Opladen zum
Beispiel mit diesen S-Bahn Filzstiften
oder ihr nehmen noch diese Glitzersteine
die sind auch essbar ist noch oben drauf
dann ist es noch ein bisschen
weihnachtlich winterlicher aber süße
Botschaften drauf sind auch schön
[Musik]
okay frohe Weihnachten Torgau frohe
Weihnachten
[Applaus]
Zeit ist mindestens genauso schön
Plätzchen backen Lichterketten wenn ihr
nur riechen könntet also wenn ihr noch
riechen könntet wie es hier riecht es
ist unglaublich übrigens
ausgezeichnet Ehre stockgrip Erde
stockkrebs Sonja die erste
gell
also 20
Sonja die erste
die sonja ist die Freundin von der Jutta
und der Jutta ist aber Opa Opa
[Musik]
jedenfalls
und die Gold Sterne
[Musik]
und das hier möchte ich noch kurz zeigen
dass Phänomen warum Makronen aufplatzen
ist wenn im Backofen so viel
Feuchtigkeit das heißt ich habe vorhin
noch gesagt so
dreimal klug nicht im Dampfbackofen
Backen habe ich sag mal ein bisschen
unter der Kamera gesagt ich weiß gar
nicht habe ich es euch erzählt unter
meinem Team erzählt was mir glaube ich
gesagt habe jedenfalls Makronen sollte
man nicht im Dampfbackofen backen weil
dann der Dampf nicht raus kann die
Feuchtigkeit weil der Backofen sehr
dicht ist entweder müsst ihr dann immer
mal die Backofentür öffnen und dann
rauslassen dampfen
oder ihr backt eben in den Backofen der
keine Dampffunktion hat oder halt mit
Volldampf und jetzt habe ich natürlich
den Fehler gemacht habe zwei Bleche
gleichzeitig gebacken deswegen sind sie
auch aufgeplatzt aber ich muss sagen
sieht so oh das will man essen aus
[Musik]
mein Gott
was ist geil
es ist lecker ich darf das Wort nicht
mehr sagen
[Musik]
diese diese Luft da drin ist
nensuppe wow
bin da jetzt noch irgendwas drüber kommt
dann dann hast du dich aus
ach so
und es kam mit den Kindern voll schön
machen oder so das ist das Haus vom
Nikolaus und nebenan Weihnachtsmann und
nebenan vom Osterhase der mit der großen
Nase nee dann wird es nicht geben
ich glaube es geht nur dreimal insgesamt
[Musik]
oh Gott das ist für Kinder voll süß
aber im Kindergarten kann man das auch
machen ja
ja also alle Erzieherinnen macht der
Grundschullehrer das ist cool
wegen des Orangensafts würde ich mal
sagen eine Woche im Kühlschrank
ansonsten Mandeln das wird ja alles
nicht schlecht aber Orangensaft ich
würde sagen hier draußen lagern sondern
wirklich einpacken in den Kühlschrank
und dann habt ihr immer was Leckeres für
unterwegs und ich finde Hammer die Hände
werden nicht schmutzig durch die Opladen
ist eine tolle lecker
und selbst wenn man Datteln nicht mag
ich finde man schmeckt nach draußen
schmeckt einfach gut
Süße ist da Lebkuchen
ihr findet auf meinem Kanal und in
meiner App noch viele viele weitere
Rezepte mit Opladen oder auch andere
weihnachtsplätzchenrezepte schaut gerne
einfach in meiner App vorbei da gibt's
die Kategorie Plätzchen da gibt's nur
Plätzchen und dann gibt's auch noch die
Kategorie Weihnachten da findet ihr so
viele Weihnachtsrezepte das heißt fängt
jetzt gerne an mit der
Weihnachtsbäckerei ich freue mich auf
euer Feedback schreibt mir auch gerne
was eure Lieblingsplätzchen sind und was
ihr euch vielleicht noch so wünscht von
mir bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]